[Music]
[Applause]
darren waller raiders tight end working
with uh sports media network blue wire
teaming up with darren with uh an
international yoga instructor uh a
mind mindfulness teacher personal
development coach donnie starkins they
have a podcast called comeback stories
and the launch date is going to be july
11th and uh darren joins us on the
program are you uh how long did it take
to get over the loss to the bengals in
the playoffs
um
it stung for a bit uh i don't i don't
really dwell too much uh in losses for a
while and you take what you what you
learn from it for us it's uh you know
red zone execution
on offense
and uh we gotta be able to do that so
learn that lesson and try not to wallow
in it and have self-pity and just move
on
but your life experiences i don't want
to say you don't sweat the small stuff
but given what you've been through
a loss to the playoffs compared to
you know what you've been going through
since you were 15 years of age how would
you compare those two
um
i would say
a playoff loss is
uh
i call it cadillac problems these days
you know life is a lot better you know i
can i can keep a job these days i can
contribute to the good that's going on
around you know the organization and the
community so now it's like okay we got
our little taste and now uh we want to
go for go for the higher things but if i
told you seven years ago
you're gonna be a pro bowl player
you're gonna be on a playoff team you're
gonna be one of the best titans in the
nfl you would have said what
i would have said you're full of crap
yeah
what what was the day that you said
i need help
uh august 12 2017 was the day i said i
needed help
walk me through that day that led you to
that
announcement
um august 12 2017 was the first day
i was sober um i
had an overdose on august 11 2017 so
you know coming out of that was the
first time i was kind of shocked to my
core and was like you know i'm not
really in control i'm actually
being controlled here you know so
that next day out of fear out of just
not knowing
uh and not feeling like i was capable of
controlling my life anymore that was
when i was like all right i'm willing to
to listen at least to what somebody else
has to say
you remember the first time you got high
uh yeah i do i was 15 some of my friends
some friends that i had had uh
you know they were taking pills out of
their parents medicine cabinets
and
i was over there hanging out and
there i was told it would make me feel
good and
you know at that time you know i was
just kind of lost as a kid trying to
find my identity and where i fit in and
what i was about so i was willing to try
it and then you know it was off to the
races from there what did it make you
feel like
um it's just anxiety went away um i felt
a sense of
calm that i never really felt before uh
everything just kind of quieted down
inside of me and that's
all that i wanted
when did you realize you had the talent
to be able to play
well may i'll start with college but
when did you realize okay i can i can do
this in college and maybe do this for a
living
um i thought it was my junior year where
i thought i could do it in college
because that was my first year playing
varsity and i played safety back then
and i had i ended up having like 120
tackles in like nine games
and so i was like i feel like i could do
like i don't know i just had i just felt
like i had a feel for the game you know
it wasn't a lot of like big thunderous
hits or anything like that it was just
like being in the right place and having
instincts to
and just being able to execute with good
form you know so
from there i was like i know i know i
could probably i could play in college
at least get my school paid for
how do you deal with pain
considering you probably can't take
anything for that pain
uh yeah i mean it's a whole lot of
different things for me it's uh you know
infrared sauna you know contrasting hot
and cold
a lot of massages a lot of cupping a lot
of needling
um
good amount of icy hot um
you know it's so it's it's a lot it's a
lot of different things for me because i
know i can't go that route so
i just make sure that i'm on top of it
day in and day out because if i'm not
then i'm putting myself in a bind what
do you want people to take away from
this podcast
um so from come back stories i want
people to take away that you know even
the people that they see as most
successful and
maybe like they have no chinks in their
arm or that they face
the same issues that any normal human
being would face on a day-to-day basis
from what's going on inside their head
inside their heart uh things that
they're dealing with from their past
they're trying to get over uh just
conversations to let people know that
you know no matter how many times
they've fallen or you know like me
getting arrested getting suspended time
after time after time like you can still
make something good happen with your
life and you still have the power to you
know rewrite your story
what was that that day like when you got
arrested
um which one i've been rushed three
times
okay the worst one was or the most
embarrassing one the most embarrassing
one i don't know if i told the story
publicly so this was at the end of my
rookie year
uh in baltimore and
you know we didn't make the playoffs and
you know they give the speech of you
know
make wise decisions don't do anything
stupid and
i was arrested in roanoke virginia in
like 36 hours
with uh for driving like 100 something
miles per hour and i had like over an
ounce of weed on in the car
what did john harbaugh say
uh i mean they weren't they weren't very
thrilled you know the first person i
called was the uh
team security uh
and they were like all right man like
you know you want you gotta have to call
a coach i was like yep and then so you
know i just called him on my way home
because i still had once i got to jail i
still had seven more hours to drive home
to georgia oh boy so it was a very long
ride a lot to think about
how are you alive
by grace of god man i don't know any
other reason ain't by my own i know that
but you start at an early age and you
know we're all our metabolisms are all
different so drugs affect us differently
and then what our body wants and
you know those who can you know just say
no if you believe in that but
like your body then like it becomes your
your way of life you you wake up that's
how you get through the day
by taking those pills is that a fair
assessment of what you went through
yeah it's like anything
and you know it was it was drinking for
me too so it's like you know anything
good happens i'm gonna get high anything
bad happens i'm gonna get high i'm
stressed out i'm gonna get high if i'm
chilling and you know just
nothing going on that day i'm gonna get
hot so it's like literally there's not
really anything that
i could do without
partaking in that and it's like you know
you basically
relearn how to live life again
yeah it's interesting you bring it up
that hey i'm feeling good let's feel
even better hey i'm bummed out i want to
feel a little bit better that i'm bummed
out
right yeah that's exactly it
was there anybody there who realized
what you were throwing away and tried to
kind of grab you and say what are you
doing
um pretty much everybody you know
harbaugh was one of those people no
prior to that when
you know probably when you didn't know
you had a problem but did you have
anybody of any of your buddies who said
hey what are you doing like you got a
chance to do something great
um yeah i had uh friends that would say
that you know in in college especially
because i was when a lot of the stuff
started happening as far as me getting
in trouble but whenever somebody would
say that you know i would just kind of
push them away keeping my arms length
you know i had even back then i had my
family at arm's length i had anybody
that you know
remotely thought they had a relationship
with me had no idea what was really
going on like people will still hit me
to this day like i had no idea and then
we were like you know close like we hung
out with each other every day or we were
around each other a lot of time and you
know i was just really great at masking
it
we're talking to darren waller the
raiders tight end pro bowl tied in and
the podcast comeback stories with uh
blue wire and the launch date is july
11th
um and then your fooling team like you
think you're fooling people but you're
not fooling anybody
you know right
yeah i mean i was told on multiple
occasions i've told and heard you know
that it's like you know this guy is
living like a double life you know
because i could be in the building and i
could be respectful to your face and put
a smile on tell a joke you know do all
that but you know when i left the
building it was like there was no
telling what was going to happen you
know a phone call somebody was going to
get what they may see in the news you
know
but i wonder you got cut by the ravens
was that a good thing
uh yeah that was a really good thing
actually because you know i was coming
off of uh i got reinstated
and you know before that i was working
at sprouts so i'm like okay like you
know i think i'm humble enough and then
it's like i come back into training camp
so you're at a supermarket you're
working uh you're stocking shelves at a
at a supermarket
yep that was my job and um well you
could get the high shelves though you
didn't need help to get up there
they always came and found me to get
some off top shelf
did anybody recognize you like you know
who you look like that guy used to play
football
yeah there are some i mean yeah i would
see people that i knew went to like high
school with girls that i used to try to
holler at so it was like it was an
interesting
interesting dynamic in there for sure
have you spoken at the rookie symposium
i haven't no why not
i don't know i didn't
never got an invite
but you should i mean that yeah that's
actually a good idea no this is what
people this is what these younger
players need i mean
they come in and they think they know
everything and they know
nothing seriously yes i think it would
be i think it'd be great i mean we look
at the nfl is littered with these
players like johnny manziel
like if somebody would have grabbed him
earlier maybe
maybe he's still playing in the nfl
yeah you're probably right but then at
the same time you know i look at my
situation and i'm like it didn't matter
what people were telling me like you
know uh you know this chris herron story
yeah
i heard him speak multiple times and
then went immediately and got high 15
minutes after he spoke
so it's like was i ready to receive
something back then did it happen have
to happen like in the exact timing in
which it did i don't know
yeah and if people haven't heard chris
herron speak
google him a former college basketball
player he was with the celtics wearing
his uniform his warm-ups he'd go out on
the uh to the curb at the loading docks
and he would get some oxy and he's
playing in an nba game
that's messed up
yeah
did you play high
uh yeah i have
wow yep in the nfl
yeah
i remember yeah i remember uh games
where you know
i don't know i was just like so
uninspired and just with life itself
like
it'd be like cocaine sometimes to just
be like i remember times i was telling
i'd be like yawning
and just not there just not into
anything not feeling any kind of
you know fire for life so i was like
yeah i needed that to just like you know
make the experience
more of what i wanted it to be i guess
you were bored
yeah i had no desire i mean i had no
desire to play football because football
became a people-pleasing tool
after high school it wasn't like the
game that i enjoyed when i grew up it
was just like all i saw was pressure all
i saw was politics all i saw was
me needing to perform instead of just
going out there and just enjoying what i
do with people that i enjoy being around
i know you never met him uh your great
grandfather the jazz musician fats
waller
what do you know about fat swallower
um i know he was a jazz pioneer
um
i know he basically created like stride
piano and all that and though he got
kidnapped by al capone to play music but
he made a lot of money wait darren you
got to lead with that that he got
kidnapped by al capone
like nobody else had no other musician
has that where al capone's guys now i
think the story is fats was performing
got done performing al capone's people
came in and said no you're we're going
to kidnap you you're going to perform
for al capone at his
party does that sound right
[Laughter]
travis kelsey doesn't have that story i
mean come on
right that's um yeah people walk around
with that one on these pockets
but you have the music background here
because i know you you love music as
well but uh
how about slim waller how about that
instead of fat swallower what do you
think
it's got got a nice nice ring to it
someone's slimmer lean in it yeah yeah
but what what what's your rap you don't
want lean
like you want slim waller slim wall yeah
i like that i like that yeah all right
um who's the best tight end in the afc
west
the best tied in in the afc west hmm
i'm not i'm not really into comparisons
but i still bought the field i feel like
i'm the best in my world because all i'm
thinking about is you know how good i
want to be good that should be your
answer
i'm going to guess travis kelsey would
probably tell me the same thing that
he's the best
without a doubt
um congrats on
just getting here and uh being a pro
bowl tight end and hopefully uh slim
waller takes off and uh you know
now where's your what's your contract
status with the raiders
um at the very moment i have two years
left on my deal okay um so yeah uh in
the negotiation
phase and uh let my agent with the team
handle that i'm just focused on getting
ready for camp yeah but devonte took all
the money
[Laughter]
nah man
uh thanks for joining us thanks for
sharing and uh good luck with the
podcast that comes out on july 11th
thanks dan appreciate you thank you
that's darren waller
the uh social media the sports media
network is blue wire and uh that's where
you'll be able to hear comeback stories
focusing on real life experiences
and uh he'll be on with donny starkins
as the co-host as well
wow